all right well it wouldn't you know we
said we covered we covered kubernetes
cybersecurity it wouldn't be a good
morning if we didn't include artificial
intelligence in the mix here this is
we're very fortunate to have a set of
experts here this morning to discuss the
AI landscape how it intersects with open
source so I want to welcome all of them
to the stage why don't you all come on
up and sit here and I'll introduce each
of you so Deepak Agarwal he is the VP of
engineering and artificial intelligence
at linked in how many people here use
LinkedIn a few of you so he's
responsible for AI efforts across the
entire company please have a seat
Mazen Gilbert is vice president of
advanced technology at AT&T Labs he is
heading up a AI initiatives there as
well make sure I write list here Terry
Singh is an author AI machine learning
expert in both deep learning and AI at
Coursera and finally Rachel Thomas who's
the co-founder of fast AI please give
them a warm welcome
so I want to kick off by just having
each of you quickly talk about what
you're doing in AI what your
organization is doing and what kind of
business imperative it is for each of
you so Deepak I'm gonna start off with
you so I'll probably start with the
mission and vision of LinkedIn so
LinkedIn for those of you are on it and
for those of you who are not I'll
encourage you to sign up so our mission
is to connect talent with opportunity at
scale and again opportunity I don't mean
it in a narrow sense of just finding a
job opportunity could be any
professional opportunity and so AI and
machine learning is something that is
embedded in all our product in fact we
many times refer to be the oxygen of our
product right so it kind of is a
horizontal layer that permeates all our
product so if you are on LinkedIn and
you are looking for a job all the job
recommen
you get is all powered through machine
learning in AI if you're a recruiter
trying to source a candidate then the
search results which you are getting is
the powered through AI if you're on the
newsfeed consuming content that's all
powered through you if you're trying to
connect with someone which you should
for getting professional opportunities
in the future those recommendations are
power to you so it's kind of ubiquitous
and we have been doing it for a long
time now it's very mature and we are no
longer in a state where we think about
it it is kind of become an integral part
of everything we do it's embedded in
everything we do I think we are now at a
state where you're thinking of what can
we do with AI to power the next
generation of user experience on the
platform Mazen you guys are running some
huge networks out there with hundreds of
millions of users and 5 G's just around
the corner yeah all right so you're
tootin to say it's so I TNT which I'm
hoping that 95% of you guys are AT&T
customers today so thank you very much
so a tnt's mission is is to really
connect people would their world whether
they live where they work and really do
it better than anybody else and when you
think about company who's who's their
sole business is communication and
entertainment ai is a foundation not
just to drive one application but really
to drive how we live and how we work as
a society and basically globally so if
you're thinking about well how would we
drive Porgy and go into 5g and how do we
really xscape cloud technologies all the
way to the edge or really how do we try
to try to drive our network how do we
operationalize our network we talked
about security earlier on how do we make
sure we get you know tens of millions of
attacks every day on our network how do
we really address those really AI is the
foundation of pretty much our business
from the get-go so I'm gonna start with
the mission and the vision no I'm just
kidding so my name is teri I am a
founder CEO neuroscience researcher
studying brain and that kind of stuff
deep cough other AI I'm also mentor
of course are working with couple of
smart people Andrew and a bunch of other
guys or developing deep learning
specialization so uh help you know if
you're this year we have a plan to get
about a couple hundred thousand to about
a million people are trained in deep
learning and AI and an amazing amazing
training set up you know from Stanford
and Andrews setting it up and I guess I
know you do that a lot of stuff as well
as faster i but so so you know very
short what I do is I work with
enterprises and and helping specifically
they could be engineers software
developers or they could be PhD postdocs
as well training them to work with deep
learning techniques right convolution
neural networks or vision or text kind
of stuff you know for the guys who don't
understand but so the goal is for me the
goal is to convert a whole lot of people
to adopt artificial intelligence or deep
learning and and the other part of the
things that I do I'm not working with
the enterprise I've worked in the most
difficult parts of the world
I go to Tunisia I even go to Syria and
and we work with women and these are
young girls you know having all kinds of
problems in the world and and for
instance after this I'm good at Chinese
here after I'm done with this conference
and then we go to Turkey but we have you
know people who were totally distracted
with everything that life can take out
of you and put those kids and say let's
go and work and let's work with code
let's work with tensorflow
and and this is this is what what I do
so I guess I this is a bit of an
introduction that's amazing that that is
incredible thank Rachel I you're checked
out your book this is the practical deep
learning for coders so lots of coders in
the audience here Rachel Thomas and
co-founder of fast AI which is a
non-profit research lab and I'm also a
professor at the University of San
Francisco and with fast AI we're trying
to make deep learning easier to use and
so we do this both through kind of
building the tools we have an
open-source library
and it's kind of very high-level and
encodes best practices called fast AI
and we also have a free course practical
deep learning for coders over a hundred
thousand students have taken it we've
had students get jobs at Google brain
have their work featured on HBO
but we're particularly trying to reach
coders you don't have to have any
advanced math background and we're
interested in people that are I think we
took Euler they're kind of working on
projects outside the mainstream things
they very care about very much care
about and don't have access to a lot of
resources and we've had students improve
agricultural loans in India try to stop
illegal deforestation of endangered
rainforests help patients with
Parkinsons diseases so a lot of
interesting applications very very cool
well I want you know for a lot of I get
these questions all the time a lot of
people in the audience find sort of the
AI landscape totally confusing right
that there's all these different tools
and there's how you do it I think you're
all kind of the exception and that
you're in roles where you're just far
down that path but like you know if
you're talking to someone who is maybe
confused about it what are some of the
exciting areas what are the some of the
things that people should be looking at
right now in AI I think I'll just kind
of go back around Robin you're starting
with you debug yeah so I think first of
all AI before 2012 was very different
than what it is today and in 2012
something great happened so you know a
bunch of professors researchers they
were able to figure out a new way of
computing things that scale by using GPU
cards and this is what kind of ushered
in the euro VRA right so I would
definitely want you to pay attention to
everything that's happening in deep
learning so what what has happened is
that you have with the with the
availability of cloud computing data
management has become commodity
right and various and with the
availability of deep learning tools and
you know things like Ostia and what
Andrew is doing slowly that's also
becoming commoditized so if you have a
problem where you know you want to
predict something by using a lot of
input signal this is slowly getting
commoditize then this alone can be
transformative look at what has happened
in computer vision look at what has
happened in natural language processing
in speech I mean these things have
become very more accurate than what they
were like ten years ago and the impact
of that is pervasive right you know in
every area now we are kind of we are
able to use AI technology do think that
we are not able to do before like for
instance in the old days if you're a
radiologist you will actually send the
MRI image to India I know and then
someone there is going to read the image
and so in the morning you have it on
your desk you don't have to do that
anymore right I mean you can have an AI
software kind of do that for you and
again I can go on and on with with the
examples so definitely supervised this
is this class of problem area predicting
some output based on input that's called
supervised learning and this is slowly
getting commoditized and this alone can
actually have a very big impact in many
different things that you do right so
you have this paradigm that you can have
data learn itself learn learnt patterns
through through algorithms right you
don't have to write rules to kind of
program a computer you can have a
computer learn there are other areas
that are not very well that are not very
well researched and we have a long way
to go like if you look at unsupervised
learning or human level intelligence
that machine can learn that's still an
open research area and I think in the
next ten years or so maybe we will be we
will be there and it may become as
commoditized as the supervised learning
techniques are how about you massive
like you know you've been involved in
some pretty cutting-edge stuff in terms
of trying to get this technology out
there and deployed you know a plug a cue
miss a little bit for you you know in
terms of building a marketplace where
you these things can be reused what's
exciting to you so just for those who
don't know means that I I did my PhD in
the 80s and neural nets for speech I was
excited about AI because the the concept
of getting at
computer to use neural nets which at the
time there is there was this resemblance
of artificial neural nets with the
biological knew and that's still today
there's that sort of association and
confusion
to get them to have a machine actually
articulate sounds and speak just like
humans do was was just amazing and
completely fascinating and that's how he
how started and we were at the time like
few hundred people we will go to
workshop we will go to conferences and
even in the past twenty years thirty
years is that there's been phases of
interest of AI Gwent fell buzz to a hype
it went down again if you look at the
literature deep learning and neural nets
an AI never actually stopped in the
community and the research community is
being worked on for for at least three
decades it is different now and I agree
with Deepak here that the distributed
computing the GPUs the the flux of
larger data is is really made a big
change well what I actually think that a
bigger driver to that we started with a
few hundred people today thanks to you
guys that we have hundreds of thousands
going to the millions really the big
driver the big revolution is open source
if you think before is there you know
twenty years ago and I was working on
this is there there are a few of us who
can write some code we would join very
large companies who have deep pocket to
have big computers great great computers
and others to be able to run these type
of jobs that can require a lot of data
today if you've gone to CES every
company is now an AI company because to
really be in that business now it's
nothing more than just download a
software and you can just get going and
you can take a course at Coursera or
somewhere and you can pretty much get
going in a very very short period of
time and by doing that that's really
trying to have created a huge revolution
in the industry so what we did however
that even with that excitement
revolution from a company like AT&T and
probably most of you are the same is
that we are hitting big bottlenecks and
our bottlenecks we believe those
bottlenecks are tremendously large
bottlenecks that AI cannot
move to that next step of scale without
addressing those the first one is that
it's still the case that there are lack
of understanding and and and and
training and learning about what AI is
of where it can be used there are a lot
of tools out there and the question is
that which tool do you use and are they
interconnected with each other we needed
to figure out a way to harmonize those
number two when you ask your team I need
to build an AI solution they would go
and start from pretty much from scratch
there is no reusability of AI these are
very expensive things to build it takes
months it may say take more years or so
so what acumen is trying to do which we
have announced on the Linux Foundation
is that to create a marketplace a
marketplace a distributed marketplace
for AI so think of the App Store with
one difference is that with this app
store is that the applications are built
by many different tools it's agnostic to
the tool that's being used that's number
one number two is that the applications
that you build in this marketplace they
interconnect and interoperate think of
them as micro services that interconnect
so you could be using tensorflow and she
could be using so I could learn and you
can actually connect the APIs of those
to create new solutions the third thing
is when we talk about machine learning a
lot of people talk about data scientist
and machine learners and so forth and
then when you start thinking about what
does it take to move that into
production from an AT&T it's sometimes
months a year two years you have to
figure out funding you have to get our
prioritization you have to put a team
together the developers don't think the
same way as the data scientists in fact
these are completely different
organizations okay that may be they
report to the same you know seeing a VP
at some point when we try to do with a
qumari just streamlining the process
from a data scientist building a model
to that model being completely
production and do that in a matter of
minutes as opposed to what it takes
today and really have that as part of a
marketplace that you can just download
and run on any cloud and be agnostic to
the cloud so I this is a very big
revolution it's a community we're all
trying to really get together to change
that I
actually believe that without doing that
it's gonna be very hard for us to really
move to where we are today where we are
deploying AI for some applications to
really making AI mainstream we're
practically a 12 year old kid who can
design and build and deploy a website
can basically do the same thing where
they are well Terry it sounds like you
just so degree are doing that right
you're working with young kids and
they're able to take this open-source
tooling and do real things with it like
what are your experiences there so yeah
I think the the point that you've raised
on open-source is something we we just
kind of assume you know it's like like
fresh water you pick it up and you start
building stuff so I want to say first
thing is I I wouldn't know how to take
these technologies either to the
enterprise customers or into Syria which
I am going to be there on the 19th
amazing you know we're gonna be getting
getting coverage from CNN and BBC and a
couple other guys that's amazing
but I almost forget then if it was not
for you know you know I contributor
chance or flow as well you know you can
just go how to be developer it's all
open source it's like free you know it's
like free as in super free that's that's
great really I mean it's something I can
just get out my hard disk and I can go
and I can implement and and you can set
up our servers you can set up virtual
machines also free you can splurt up on
VirtualBox you know free opera okay
I think Oracle is bought it but it's
still free you can download it so you
know I think that is something which I
realized when I had a question so Angela
she said sent me a list of questions to
all of us and I said hey you know this
is the revolution it's like a silent
revolution I'm you know guys the Richard
Stallman all these guys everybody's been
working on it it's it's really super we
should be like super thankful for
everybody all these millions of
developers who make this happen so I can
just pick up my laptop and and I can go
to Tunis where I'm gonna be in Tunis and
there are like people pulling me all
over the place so the political parties
saying why don't you talk about AI
because we need to really clear the air
okay fines I'm gonna make a business II
kind of presentation as long as you
don't talk about that stupid robot
called Sophia but everything else is
free you can take it and you can just
implement it guys and and the practical
example is this so I said okay so I have
free stuff so what do I do and then you
know so we said okay there is you know I
can go into details I'll keep a little
high level for example skin cancer
detection is is something which you know
you have you know human bias and then
you have technology and and I said okay
so are you know that stuff is free as
well you can download it I have all
those data sets in fact you know like I
don't know it's like 40 or 50 gigabytes
I can put it on my flash disk and just
go anywhere and we can train on those
data sets provided by us I see this
international skin image classification
society here in the u.s. there are a
whole lot of data sets from skin cancer
images and just identifying your moles
or you know those kind of you know if
it's a malignant or if it's benign of
its neighbors you know people have been
teaching me different things I'm not a
surgeon but it's it's like okay so we
have free software and then we have a
problem which we can solve and then what
that led to I gave a bunch of lectures
on different you know researching
capsules just like ten people in the
world or researching on capsules
building stuff and and capsule networks
is like the next let's say convolution
your network thing or the evolution of
that and and so we take that and then I
said okay so we're going to take a step
further who wants to develop an app in
android free stuff again and okay core
ml with Apple is also free you can
download it in Kimball an iOS app as
well and people are building apps right
now so I'm just back from Finland where
I know if Martin's still in the room you
you know being in Espoo and they were
like really smart researches and we're
building apps so it's all possible I
didn't have to go in anybody to ask
money or permission from a manager who
would say I need to talk to an account
manager because this big corporate
company needs to give you software and
when you have softer you need licenses
you need this you need that so it's it's
just available it's it's it's super
amazing rich I want to ask you though a
question
that I get a lot it you know I I agree I
think that we're standing on the
shoulders of giants in terms of folks
like Richard Stallman who came up with
this concept of sharing and critical
open source licenses and all the folks
who followed that you know whether it
you knows folks from Apache or other
organizations but one question that we
keep hearing is all right that's code
what about data right how you know is is
data the new proprietary right is this
where one thing that so I think there's
some misconceptions and that a lot of
people think that yeah you need Google
size datasets and you need you know like
millions of dollars worth of GPU power
to do deep learning and those aren't the
case and so kind of getting to your
question about this like what if you
don't have the data a lot of people are
releasing pre-trained models so you know
someone has a large data set train a
model they release that model and then
you can do something called transfer
learning where you are fine-tuning that
to a much smaller data set so we had a
student download I think it was just 20
pictures of people playing baseball 20
pictures of people playing cricket and
trained a classifier to tell cricket
from baseball just using 40 images and
that's something because they were using
this pre-trained net you know and just
fine-tuning the last layers and so
there's really amazing potential there I
think in terms of being able to get deep
learning to work on smaller datasets and
it's part of why it's so important that
people do share their weights and their
models
openly through open-source yeah you know
we worked on a data sharing license
agreement that would with both a
copyleft one which would be a share back
yeah license then a permissive license
which you just didn't didn't need to do
that but we're trying to get ahead of
this ability to kind of share yeah and
there are issues because it's like I
mean data you know this is an important
part of you know the of how models are
trained but there's also so much around
privacy and anonymous you know true
anonymization is almost impossible and
there have been several kind of
high-profile cases of people thinking
they've been on mised
and then it's bendy anonymized and so I
think there is kind of a bit of a
tension sometimes between yeah wanting
to protect privacy and yeah like it is
really important though to be sharing
models and your training process yeah I
wanted him to mess in here because you
know me you're the telecommunications
work it's very very competitive but you
know to her point what our data said
that you would want to share I don't
know cell tower maintenance or whatever
that just isn't a competitive per se but
kind of follows that open source
philosophy of like hey this is just data
we won models that we just want to share
with it do you see patterns there and so
I I think the idea of having companies
share data is not new as being people
been talking about this for several
decades we've never cracked it we've
we've never created an open shareable
infrastructure community where people
can easily with security can share data
with HIPAA requirements and their
privacy rules I think we're starting to
get almost there I think with you guys
and and a lot of the policies you guys
putting in place and that's what I'm
hoping we're gonna do with activists a
chemist's cannot really succeed without
having a really clear understanding of
the data behind it from an AT&T they're
obviously data we can't share there's no
doubt about that you know we we carry
data and we track data about cell
coverage so with those kind of data we
cannot share but there are other data
that we actually we want to do as part
of the arguments to consider whether we
can open a community looking at that
just like you mentioned with transfer
learning one of the we're a very
capital-intensive company so you can
imagine that one of the things we do we
send people app we own millions of poles
we own thousands of cell sites macro
cells small cells etc we send people
literally up a pole to go and check a
cell to see if there's something wrong
with it if a wire is disconnected it's
rusty if there is dirt etc what we're
trying to do now with transfer learning
and is there we sent a drum and that
drone has visual capabilities that drone
detect whether there is what the object
is looking at and we can't do that we
don't have enough data to do that so
we've
just collected few hundreds of those
data points and then that drones looks
at to see if that object has a rust and
if that's the issue that we can perhaps
do something about or send somebody
there or not
ninety-five percent of the time we don't
need to send somebody so there's a
safety aspect we're using this for we
could never do that
by collecting significant amount of data
we can only do it with small set of data
but thanks to the open source community
by having models it's not just data
people think of data as raw data and I
think raw data is very important and
there are situations we cannot share raw
data for many reasons but there are
they're derivatives of data there are
probably an area we need to talk more
about which is that when you build these
models these models now reflect weights
and and capabilities that that resemble
the data you cannot probably do a
reverse engineering they hide the
privacy aspect but those models can be
shared and those models with some
additional new data can do something
really remarkable and that's exactly the
kind of things you're talking about
deepak how about you like at linkedin
are there similar patterns where you're
finding these for commodity components
like you know how do you make those
decisions how are you doing yeah I think
so I agree with everything so one thing
I would like to mention even if you if
you're a developer we provide developer
API is where you can actually get
information about LinkedIn public
profile information right so for
instance you can you can you can use the
API is to get a person's job title or
you know if you want more information
about a company like how many employees
work there and how many people have
changed up so these are things that are
available to the developer API is there
are some other information that we
provide to companies those are not
available for free so you have to talk
to us and based on the use case we can
still provide that to you so that's
already happening now I think one
example for instance I can give you
right away for instance you know one of
the things challenges we face on our
news feed is there is a lot of
non-professional content that gets like
things like hate speech and porn and
things like that so we don't build those
models from the scratch like for
instance there have been a lot of nice
models that have been built by using
image net data using resonate and again
we use the same technique like the top
of the last two layers of the neural net
and then customize it for our use cases
we have a lot of different teams that
are working with different problems so
we have a notion of what we call
internally a feature marketplace right
so features are signals that go into a
machine learning models and we don't
want every team to be building the same
signals over and over again so there is
this there is the there is a framework
which where you know if you create a
certain user interest vector for
instance or signal that kind of captures
a user interest you can actually share
it with every other team right so it
goes into the future marketplace that
anyone can then grab it and start using
it in their model so that's how we are
scaling it and you know we are in a
world where we are we are not just doing
machine learning where we don't have
only experts to in machine learning
anymore we have opened up the machine
learning to every single software
engineering the company so we have
training programs where every software
engineer can get trained in machine
learning we have each or marketplace
these think of these as cookie cutter or
prefabricated features if you were right
so if you are a developer you take a
course you have prefabricated features
available in the marketplace and you
have a problem that you want to solve in
the product you can go take this
prefabricated features build a model and
deploy it in your product you don't even
have to talk to an expert in many cases
ok I had a question swearing I want to
I'll start with you terian didn't want
to go to Rachel in Meza and come back to
you d [ __ ] that it's not necessarily on
our list of questions so I'm going to
surprise you surprise so you have a lot
of developers and people who care about
coding out here and curricula remember
this on the 25th anniversary of Linux I
made a toast the kernel community and
folks saying you know congratulations on
25 years of Linux and I want to announce
our next big project after Linux which
is an artificial intelligence and that
is actually self a self coding platform
so drink up the
tonight's your last night of employment
but this is I get this question all the
time in their startup there's a start-up
in Spain called sourced which just
cashed all the code that's on github and
ever been written in a lot of other
repositories just as experts I'll start
with you Terry when are we gonna get to
self-aware Cody like to have ability to
either like as you're coding to use AI
to improve the quality or to actually
have self coding systems crazily I get
this question all the time you know what
you probably are never gonna get and I
hope you're not gonna ask about these
generally I kind of thinks because I
kind of shut down no I get it I told ya
the evil robots - yeah this is
specifically I think the most beautiful
thing is that there's a whole lot of
code out there the intuitions behind the
way the code has been written is not
something you can encapsulate in
software and create a kind of an
automated software development kind of
library that says you know these guys
are great in in convolutional neural
networks image classification kind of
technology that these guys are great in
in recurrent neural networks this
advanced kind of you know text analysis
and making kind of predictions what you
will not get is the intuition of what is
coming next so as long as you are
building things for instance just an
example we know you know there's been
delay and and I've studied astronomy as
well so I really really follow a whole
lot of things in a code also on the side
to to understand how we're kind of you
know learning about gravitational waves
and all that so we have web going into
the space next year sometime in June and
it keeps getting delayed it's really sad
but anyways so we're gonna get huge
humongous amount of data coming out of
the universe at us and and to do that
you that's you know that software which
we are super excited and self
congratulating that you know we have
great software it's not gonna help to a
certain extent it will definitely help
in best practices and and you know doing
unit testing and all those things
definitely huge scope in making those
things were
and automating it I say really I think
we should automate that so from that
perspective I think shouldn't worry too
much about jobs getting out of you know
the door because there's a whole lot of
beautiful things we need to do if you
need to you know colonize Mars or
something I wanted to do is well that's
a kid I said I couldn't but you know
this gentleman from South Africa who
comes to us and says super what's your
company says just hey okay it makes
sense but so there's a whole lot of the
beautiful things we need to solve in the
universe so from that perspective that's
definite like 60s how many percent of
encapsulation of doing things which we
don't need to do anymore can be grabbed
literally from github and from even you
know best practices on Stack Overflow
whatever and you can put these and kind
of provide guidance so people don't lose
time we spend a lot of time doing a
whole lot of stuff which we should not
be doing so from that perspective I
totally agree but I don't think my
cognition as a human being a single
human being I can already envision a
universe I don't need like hundred
people to do that I can do that already
you know that power has been given to me
the other thing is my intuitions of
trying to solve a problem in it could be
any problem here right now physical
problem object detection problem is
something is has doesn't exist at all um
in in in software library what does
definitely exists as best practices
which are definitely search and and seek
out too
and so yeah I think so I guess you know
60 70 percent of that work definitely
can be automated so salt encoding well
we can call it self coding but basically
it's just grabbed information
understands how you want to follow that
logic and eventually you know throw it
into your into your algorithms and or in
your software library and do that and
the other 30% just keep you know hold on
to it you know your intelligence in your
beautiful cognition and your powers to
you know grab the universe and make it
your owner or yours they're not going
anyway they're not going away
all right quick quick last word from
Rachel Mazen and Deepak on you know
advice decoders out there and how can
they use MLA I to improve their projects
- yeah I mean I'd say with them and one
just to know that it's possible if you
know how to code you can
learn to use deep learning that domain
expertise is still incredibly valuable
and so I think something I hear a lot
from companies is you know like oh it's
so hard to hire like a Stanford PhD and
it's just that's not what you need at
all like the people that are already
working with and for you or kind of the
right people like they understand your
problem and your domain and so I guess
again this is something that I think is
like whatever and I know here's where a
lot of coders but like having
specialized knowledge around a domain is
still super crucial so this showed up
recently MIT released a deep learning
course and I don't know anything about
the course but the image that they led
with was like you know see why the
algorithm predicted pneumothorax you
know it's a picture of the lungs and a
radiologist she's also machine learning
specialist responded and was like oh
that doesn't make sense you know like
that model must have been over fitted
you know and so that like that kind of
domain expertise is going to remain very
valuable for a long time and like one of
our goals at fast AI is to kind of be
taking the domain experts and teaching
them deep learning as opposed to trying
to engage deep learning specialists with
your particular domain yep
amazing Deepak yes sir
so I think in order to machine learning
or AI you need three things one is you
need to know what your objectives are
you need to know what you're trying to
build the algorithm to do you need data
label data and then you need algorithms
that can learn from reader so if you
have a simple objective like identifying
a cat inner image that's easy I think
that is something that you can put
together very quickly like with few
lines of code because all the other
materials are available
right as long as you have label data but
let's say if I have to solve a more
complex objective like I want more users
to come to LinkedIn every day this is a
very complex objective right like users
can come to LinkedIn because they like
the newsfeed because they want to
connect to people because they want to
search for someone how do you what we do
the series of machine learning problems
that can actually solve this objective
is very difficult like this you cannot
in cost encapsulate at least today in a
software right so that's where you have
to go and understand the domain very
well do some data analysis and once you
are able to formulate those series of
objectives then again the coding is very
easy right so I would say I think in a
few years everything else will get
commoditized pretty much not completely
but pretty much and we have to spend a
lot more time understanding what you're
really trying to solve like if you want
to do job recommendations without caring
about diversity well you know if you if
your algorithm does not take care of
that it's not going to optimize for that
it's just going to optimize for a number
of applications but if you tell the
algorithm no I care about that as well
and put that as part of the object then
it's going to do something about it so
that's that's probably what's going to
happen in the next ten years as we start
commoditizing and we will be able to
solve more complex problem than what we
are able to do today um coders you know
doesn't matter what your background is
absolutely get involved do some training
and learn this field in my organization
every code every programmer hast doesn't
matter what they're they have a PhD or a
master's whatever it is 100 percent
compliance this year they all have to
learn it they all have to be able to
code machine learning and AI
capabilities AT&T in general we've put
out six months ago a plan a program that
everybody in the company where 300,000
employees to be able to go through ml AI
training even if you're a marketing or
legal or whatever we all need to know
this is not about just coders it's about
everybody we the people in the legal
team they need to understand and the
marketing team need to understand it
financial people everyone really need to
come to the same page so we go away from
every problem AI is the solution that
hype to really what are the key problems
we need to solve
from an AT&T and from even in the Coda's
is their look where the problems are
where the challenges are also I have
always tell in my team three things look
where we're spending a lot of money to
look where there are opportunities of
revenue we can have and we could do with
these technologies and three is safety
there are places where we can apply
these technologies and I mentioned the
thing about polls and the 5g for safety
and I think that's really if you can
start with a real problem just like what
deep I just mentioned real problem that
really wants a solution that's probably
a long way to go so here here if you're
not training everybody in the
organization you're gonna be caught up
in a never-ending hype cycle and that's
a pretty interesting practical way that
AT&T is handling that problem so thank
you everyone I really appreciate you
coming here today
[Applause]